walk in Rocking this watch and it's
massive Alex is supposed to guess how
much you bought that for oh okay Alex my
guess is that that watch costs
approximately
$17,500 Alex I'm guessing 85 my guess is
35 because you got a deal and you could
buy it at MSRP I go to this place called
happy Jeweler and he does a lot of
athletes and stuff like that out in
California and he just so happened to
get this watch in stock and I had text
him for months I was like if you ever
see this exact watch let me know I love
black and blue and he says I got it in
stock and he's like I'm actually going
to give it to you below cost of what I
have it at he's like just because I know
you're going to make content it's going
to help out I want to build a
relationship with you you're going to
refer me a bunch of clients which I have
you know now I'm talking about it on
this podcast right so I ended up getting
it from him for like 42,000 and I was
looking at it on eBay the other day I
think it was like worth 60 to 70 now